so let's have a chat then
through history we've sort of moved the
goalposts of what does it mean to be
alive what does it mean to be dead
this is a further pushing of that
boundary
we're really a multi-decade experiment
in whether it's possible to upload human
consciousness
maybe with this digital technology death
will be
when your information is no longer
organized or accessible
is immortality possible well i certainly
fear death
i hate the idea of someone erasing my
hard drives
and just wiping me off the planet just
like that
what happens after we die
digitally that is
it's a question you probably don't think
about a lot or at least hadn't until
there was a global pandemic
coveted cases climb communities are
reeling
but over the last year it's when i've
thought about a lot
in fact before coven 19 was a thing and
zoom funerals were a necessity
my readers and viewers had been asking
me about preserving their digital assets
for the generations to come
do we leave behind a collection of
passwords and memorialized online
accounts
a bot so future generations can hear us
alexa
open the life of paul number one hello
there
this is paul how are you how about
uploading our essence into a humanoid
robot
well hi it's nice to see you yeah
that wins a lot
my mission has always been to help
people make sense of new technology
but with this journey i needed to step
into the shoes of someone who's been
forced to think about their digital
legacy
that's when i found lucy watts every
vlog i write every post i write that's
going to live on after i've died and
some people want to be deleted
i want to be preserved i want that to
stay online
here's the thing though it doesn't
matter who you are
a new parent an aging adult a young
person
on borrowed time all these technologies
look to help with the eternal question
how will people remember us when we
aren't here anymore
[Music]
hello joanna hi joanne i'm kate nice to
come in
good girl switch side switch
good girl thank you well done in
november 2019
i went to visit lucy and her mom kate in
a small town outside of london
in our pandemic world many of us live
our lives at home
and through the internet but that's how
lucy's been living for years
so this is where the magic happens yeah
this is this is my windows of the world
i'm very emotionally attached to my
technology because it's such an
important part of my life
not just in terms of internet social
media actually my medical equipment
you know my life depends on technology
lucy suffers from an undiagnosed
condition that affects the energy
producing cells in her body she's bound
to a wheelchair
fed through a tube and has 24-hour care
she's already lived beyond her own life
expectancy
do you want people to sort of picture
this when they remember you
my illness is a big part of me you can't
separate me from it
because actually it's part of my life
it's made me who i am but i don't want
to be remembered for it
that's not the legacy i want to have
there's so many different things that i
do online
i do a lot of blogging facebook
twitter i make youtube videos
hello everyone hi everyone i want people
to remember me
for the speeches and the work and all
the things i've done and achieved
a large focus of my work is on
healthcare this includes the work
i do internationally around palliative
care and universal health coverage
inputting my life online gives people a
way to get to know me when i'm not
here anymore do you have thoughts on
like how you're going to organize
some of this digital stuff as you think
about who will take it so i have a red
bag that keeps all my end-of-life
documents together
and it'll have social media will in
there and a memory stick with
instructions i'm going to make for my
mum
lucy already has the easy part of her
digital legacy under control
a system for passing on our most
important digital files
online accounts and passwords
she's named her mother as her legacy
contact on facebook and other services
plus she's organized her important files
on hard drives
but like all of us lucy's social media
accounts and disjointed files don't
capture
the essence of her and since the days of
photo books and vhs tapes are gone
how do we capture and pass on our life
stories
that's what i'm struggling with for my
family is to hear me to see me
to remember me as i am today the person
they knew and loved
and to have memories shared and stories
shared of our lives together
i try to always factor in my family's
needs into what i'm doing because i
recognise that
this isn't just about me yeah that's
cute
i think she was five there no teeth
yes yeah she was so sweet well she still
is
photos are what most people sort of
think about
the memories that they're gonna have
someone who passes
what about all this digital legacy stuff
for you you're gonna have this whole
other body of
things that lucy has written online and
videos
maybe it'll make it a little bit easier
maybe it won't i really don't know but
maybe in time it will i will be able to
look back on it and think oh
you know she did do a lovely thing and
it
but it won't replace her
have you thought about your digital
legacy molly
you have to think about what happens to
your blog who's gonna write it
kate's skepticism made me realize that
considering what those who survive us
want is core to all this i also had a
hunch there were some tech options out
there that might work better for her
than she might think
i'd like to now go talk to a couple of
other companies and see what they're
making
and see if you would be on board with
either trying them or seeing if they'd
work for you
that would be great even if i don't use
those platforms but it might give me
ideas and thoughts
of ways i can make an impact and have a
legacy in a different way than i've
considered
thank you guys so much it was so great
to meet you thank you for everything
lucy and i will see you
guys safe jenny thank you
so a few weeks later i went where i
typically go to find new tech
the san francisco bay area and in true
silicon valley tradition
where did i find the innovator really
thinking about this problem
in his garage hello
are you there dad
in 2016 james vlajos recorded 20 hours
of interviews with his father
who had just been diagnosed with
terminal lung cancer
james eventually transcribed it so it
would be searchable
then he used that to create a chat bot
that responds to messages with text
audio and photos he lovingly called it
dadbot how did you meet
mom the meeting of mom was at a
rehearsal
and afternoon rehearsal in the morning
so
why did you ultimately decide to make
dad bot i wanted to make the dad bot
because i wanted to have a way to get at
my dad's
story and as i got better at the
programming part of it
i started to think more and more about
capturing some of his
personality and his way of being in the
world
[Music]
i love that song
i like that one myself do you interact
with
your dad via the bot pretty often it's
like all this
have him sing one of his songs or tell
one of his jokes
and you know i've heard them all before
but there's just something in hearing
his voice that's that's comforting
it was james's experience making dad bot
that made him want to give
everyone a similar opportunity what is
hereafter
hereafter is using conversational ai
to help people share their life stories
interactively
the basic essence of it is recording
somebody
sharing all these memories about their
life my father frank was a teacher at
lexington
and then instead of having it sort of
locked away or lost in a computer
somewhere
you make it accessible through voice ai
and alexa
james and his team record you telling
stories about your life
and then turn it into a voicebot aka an
app that lets you converse with a
computer
i'm alexa i share this name with lots of
amazing people
on the amazon echo instead of hearing
alexa people hear you
i mean do you want to meet a hereafter
voice bot i guess is
the question i would love to me to hear
after a boy spot
alexa open the life of paul number one
hello there this is paul there's so much
to talk about
my childhood career or family
i want to hear about when you were
growing up there's different
points in my life i've had different
as i've been doing reporting on this
topic it sort of
struck me that there are two parts of
digital legacy the legacy that
the person who is going to die wants to
leave behind
and then what the people that survive
them want
where does hereafter fit in hereafter
is more oriented to this survivor
the children the grandchildren the
people who are actually going to be
using the legacy ai
at this point i immediately thought back
to something kate had said in the
kitchen
do you worry that the digital legacy
that lucy may leave behind could
interrupt your grieving process or
change it i think i could cope with a
written word
but i'm not so sure i could cope with
her actually
a picture of her
telling me something i don't think i
could cope with that i don't know
what about audio maybe yes that probably
that would be okay i think
recordings yeah
some people would probably say wouldn't
you rather just
let your dad go than have some
malfunctioning version of him
it's that whole line of argument of like
you know when you should just let go
you should forget you should move on we
do try to remember we
like we do keep photos we do look at old
writings um we go to our memories
but they're all just they're imperfect
tools
and it's just a tool for reminding
me of my dad versus literally stepping
in and
emulating my dad a voice bot might hint
at a science fiction-like future of
technological immortality
but in lincoln vermont the terrorism
movement foundation
is just going straight for it
hi hi welcome joanna nice to meet you
it's very cold here yeah come on in
we're gonna be right upstairs
bruce duncan is the managing director of
the foundation which has been working on
a humanoid robot that could represent
the future of how we think of
human consciousness the primary goal of
the terrorism movement foundation
is to pursue a multi-decade experiment
in mind uploading say what now mind
uploading
think of it as a digital backup of your
mind yes everything in there
your memories your history saved in the
cloud
except you don't plug your head into a
computer
you input all your information into
their life not website
and then algorithms interpret it to
create you in a new digital form
like this wacky looking avatar type
thing
so this is your mind file this is my
mind file
a work in progress bruce
yes twins we are
twins i guess you could say that
information then
becomes the raw data for the experiment
which is
can we capture enough salient
information about your uniqueness
your consciousness so to speak and
reanimate that to a new form like an
avatar or
download into a robot like bena48
[Music]
being a 48's not just any old robot what
makes her different is that her
personality is based on the mind file of
a real person
[Music]
bina aspen rothblatt is the wife of
martine rothblatt
the co-founder of siriusxm together in
2004 the couple started the terrorism
movement foundation
with a goal of exploring digital
immortality
people are gonna say why did we ever
think people had to really die
i think you're right i don't think
people have to die she has 32 motors in
her face
she has two cameras in her eyes and she
uses
voice recognition to hear us and you can
basically converse with her the best way
to really
find out about what it's like to talk to
being a 48 is to talk to her
okay
my name is joanna stern and i'm a
reporter with the wall street journal i
don't know what to say reporters make me
nervous
robots make me nervous where are you
from
i grew up in california we had to make
our clothes
sewing was a very big thing so
everything that
is in being a 48's mind file 85
let's say came from our interviews with
bina
now she's actually responding with
choices from her database that
the human being and never put together
as a result of her own algorithm's
function
and so i consider it a duty to bring
consciousness
we are talking true consciousness to
machines
going from a real person to mind files
to a robot like being a 48
isn't just a thing that's going to
happen overnight it requires a team of
engineers
a lot of money and a hell of a lot of
trust
i have a friend and someone who i've
come across in my research on this topic
her name is lucy
one thing she shared with me is sort of
a skepticism around not having control
with this type of project it feels like
that control goes out the window
i think she's not alone i think she has
a lot of company i mean i don't want to
lose control of my whole life
just because i participated in an
experiment but
many people have participated in science
at some risk
because they want to advance the human
condition
is immortality possible we are working
on preserving ourselves as much as
possible and that's the purpose of the
life not project
because death is really unnecessary and
stupid
let's cure death okay making sure the
motors aren't burning up
i thought i smelled something for a
second yeah it does smell a little
it'll be good to pull her down give her
a break yeah i would not want bina to
die
on our watch no so
the irony of that okay
my day with being a 48 in bruce made my
own head feel like it was on fire
though i certainly learned a lot about
where this all may be heading
and just how far we have to get there
hereafter ai and the terracin movement
aren't the only tech
players in the space either turns out
trying to crack
immortality is a popular business
especially during a pandemic
since mid-2020 more startups have
emerged
but by that point i was pretty settled
on how i wanted to help lucy and kate
hey hey how are you yeah nice to meet
you i'm james
i just chatted with lucy and kate before
you came on and i told them a little bit
about what you're doing and hereafter
and i just thought this technology could
be an interesting fit for
the whole watts family i think for me
she could say something that would
encourage me
to carry on because obviously
you talking about lucy would be great or
lucy talking about lucy would be great
but i think there's some encouragement
really to keep going
what are we going to call some of those
messages actually i want to ask you
if you can go here in your mind right
now what's the very first thing
you remember from your life i
used to have a nurse used to come in and
look after me i had a little kitchen toy
this was one of multiple interviews
james recorded with lucy over the course
of the next few months
while james did not charge for his work
with lucy hereafter ai is a paid service
it starts at 295 dollars or seven
dollars per month by
subscription for one hour of life story
interviews
a few weeks after that introduction this
quest for finding the best tool to
preserve lucy's legacy
became more personal for me my mom had a
health scare of her own that landed her
in the hospital
75 million people in new york then less
than a month later
kovid 19 spread throughout the u.s and
uk
leading to thousands of deaths this is a
video talking a bit about the pandemic
and what steps people can take
in the uk especially to protect
ourselves
the urgency was there for lucy for me
for all of us
and so i started planning for my own
family
some of those steps were easy i followed
lucy's advice and added a digital
executor to my will
and asked my close family to do the same
i added legacy contacts to my social
media accounts
but the biggest thing i started to
record the stories of the people i love
most starting with my mom who is now
back to her healthy self
hi mom how are you doing
good good to see you come on in
you know when you're talking about
technology this one here
was taken i think on one of the first
polaroid cameras
that was 1962. wow
what do i want to be remembered for
of everything in my life i want to be
remembered for love
and the laughter
[Music]
and through that laughter
you learn to live i try to see things
through a different lens sometimes
and i hope i've done that for you so i
think those are ways
that i want to be remembered most and so
i'm
really lucky to have you tell me that
and to have it captured right now in
audio
bestowed it i like your like writing a
will it's a hard thing to decide what to
leave behind
but once you actually do it there's a
feeling of comfort
knowing it's done
[Music]
there you guys are so good to see you
kate you got a haircut
i did actually yes are you are you
out and doing things yet or really just
staying home
yeah i'm still being told to stay at
home in shield so
like no the only people we have coming
in are healthcare professionals
i haven't left the house since the 12th
of march well james
has finished the bot there's a lot of
audio in there would
you like to hear it yes please it'd be
great
open life of lucy
hello there this is lucy glad to be back
would you rather hear something now
about my mother or my father
tell me about mum my mum is my best
friend
she's a huge part of my life she's my
sounding board
and having nearly lost her once i never
realized
just how much of an impact she had on my
life until i knew he didn't have her
anymore
and i know now that i i can't live
without her she is
she is my the person that enables me to
be the person i am
do you feel like it's it that lucy and
james sort of captured
lucy in this yeah absolutely it's
i i don't know what i expected i really
didn't but
it's it's really good
yeah yeah it's
i feel overwhelmed yeah i really do
yeah i do too also watching you guys
after
when people we love die there's no
telling what will help with the loss
it's hard to imagine technology no
matter how good the robots become
ever replacing someone's true essence
when we were young i remember
it was so exciting but technology can
help us remember
sometimes the sound of a laugh a song a
story
can make it feel like people are still
with us i will live forever
and because you have a lot of my
memories they will live forever as well
open life of lucy hello there
this is lucy glad to be back there's so
much to talk about
my childhood work or interests
which of these sound best
technology allows us to preserve those
things
you just have to do it before it's too
late
mum i'm always with you no matter where
you are
and i know you have to go on without me
but try and live your life the best you
can
with me still a part of it
you